fastest growing company to go from zero
to a billion dollars was a MLM company
at that time they wrote a book about
them called the Excel phenomenon how
much were you making back then in the
MLM business yeah that was the first
time I'd ever made ten thousand dollars
in a month I was the only person the
company that signed up over 200 people
cold off the street in under 30 minutes
how I'd walk up to somebody at a coffee
shop and say hey how's it going
I say good and I'd say I noticed you
were in some construction attire are you
working on a site close to here and he
would say oh yeah I'm just on my lunch
break I was like man I was too scared of
heights to get up there and he's like I
don't like it either I was like oh you
don't like it and he'd go yes this is
temporary I was like oh what would you
like to do and then
99.9 percent of people have no idea what
they'd actually like to do which is why
they are where they are